hier éric voilà il y avait d'autres
gynéco qui étaient là et c'est vrai que
dans l'émission à gâteau coiffer à coups
de griffe à propos d'une attraction
jugés racistes et on a jugé lui aussi
sévèrement cette attraction dans un parc
de loisirs
visiblement dope n'a pas bien compris ce
qu'elle voulait dire c'est de là qu'est
partie la plaie de crise que si vous
nous rejoignez sachez que doc a quitté
l'émission et il va tout nous raconter
il va nous dire pourquoi
voilà il a quitté l'émission et ce qui
s'est passé dans sa tête mais juste
avant on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé
regardez c'était le coup de griffe
d'agathe c'est une critique souvent
cette société de l'internation s'il aime
mais parfois elle a des bien fait parce
qu'elle a permis de dénoncer à parc
d'attractions alors s'appelle nigloland
parce que donc ce parc d'attractions qui
existe depuis 1987 avait en 2019
une attraction voix qui mettait en scène
deux statues de statut d'un explorateur
vraisemblablement blanc et de son
compagnon noir qui tenait des bananes et
qui faisait des échanges ne l'est pas
oui tu vas voir en large dans un parc
d'attractions tu vas voir la vidéo
actions ou vendre des bananes c'est quoi
ce par tous va bien le voir
[Rires]
alors cela par l'attraction il ya des
crampes avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'était la première partie de la sphère
et donc doc a l'air un petit peu
perturbé et il semble redécouvrir
qu'eric naulleau notre ami et
chroniqueur dans l'émission regardez je
les voie moi j'avais pas envie de les
voir me disait regarde moi un problème
fait des signes de loin c'est pour faire
mais de parler des gens un peu plus là
en face de moi eric naulleau sa wii fait
partie des missions ouamer j'arrivais
pas à comprendre
là bas j'ai rien compris d'un bout à
l'autre
explications vous connaissez pas ce que
vous étiez dans balances ton post ans au
plus d'un de la galerie moi c'est le
moment de télévision le plus étrange que
j'ai vu à oui c'est vrai je suis en face
de quelqu'un que j'aime bien c'est que
vous l'adorez en plus non mais je mène
bien exagéré mais tu l aimes bien avec
kia jab jamais aucun dossier aucune
embrouille et qui d'une minute à l'autre
construit un délire mais de toutes
pièces insultes et menaces
agathe insultes et menaces et monte dans
les tours on peut plus le faire
redescendre ce nom mais parce que c'est
doc mais il est s'attendent à voir mais
il vous dire pourquoi ces patients a dit
il va nous expliquer et après tout va
s'éclaircir chez vous également ça a
continué mission continue puisque une
page de pub passe il ya nos invités à m
sila et alban villeneuve qui sont
arrivés en plateau et soudain badoc il
est dans son délire ce soir pour ce
deuxième doit on veut on veut que qui
fait on veut que tout neuf
j'ai super content mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
mais hier l'avocat et des indices un
super bon mais c'est notre ami il est
dans l'émission on fait un petit
changement de lieu parce qu'il a mais
qui s'est passé entre vous mais rien
rien c'est pas si vous voulez qu'on
repasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'étais avec d'autres gynécologue
immune explique je m'explique voilà je
m'expliquais plein de choses et cette
nuit je dors très tôt que je regarde le
us open
voilà tous les soirs donc je me couche
je me réveille tôt parce que pour
regarder les matches de tennis et je
note gynéco a fait une vidéo vous vous
insultez les cov et vous allez samassa
qui secoue ta g où ils pensent que vous
êtes des mises et oui voilà c'est voilà
ce qu'ont allons tester vous des
tractions à regarder vous savez c'est
magnifique
cette histoire il faut leur garde mais
j'ai mangé contraire je suis à jeun es
là
vous avez passé
monsieur naulleau
je sais pas exactement ce prix là il
s'est déguisé dans un sens il ses nuits
dans il a été maître un costume de singe
il invente une rubrique existait pas il
a inventé un parc d'attractions qui
n'existait même pas donc voilà il n'y a
pas de banal il n'y a pas de
y'a pas de parc où les gens font
grossièrement
en grosses firmes en l'axant africain ça
n'existe à la déjà c'est beaucoup plus
clair ouais j'ai vous donc doc est avec
nous ce soir mon ami et c'est quand même
mon frérot est avec nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à tétouan alors mon dock chéri on va
passer deux heures là dessus donc je
suis très content que tu sois la mersey
ce que tu t'es calme et j'ai du mal à
être énervé jamais énervé en fait là non
mais en fait pas cru qu'ils allaient il
avait tourné un sketch en fait les deux
alors j'ai pensé qu'ils s'étaient
déguisés nuit en singe c'est vrai j'ai
pensé que le skate c'est une harka bah
oui c'est ça bras et donc vous êtes
c'est obscène ratera pas ce qu'il faut
faire ça écoutez non mais il suit
l'émission que partiellement
donc je en fait il s'est dit comme
agathe lance le truc
agathe s'est déguisé avec eric naulleau
il pensait que c'est un skate et c'est
vrai que ça aurait été un sketch de très
mauvais goût donc c'est pour ça
le prix n'est pas allé lui serrer la
main
bien sûr il y aura les montréalais va
dire
discutez deux minutes avant que se
serrer la main mais ce que je peux te
mangerais non non non moi j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui moi je tiens aujourd'hui je
veux bien tu entends ton mais dis moi de
me dire tu apprendras combien de temps
une alors vas-y je vais pas en rajouter
mais alors pourquoi tant rajoute maxwell
qualité films n'ont pas si mon nom m'a
dit vas-y vas-y eric non je sais pas on
a déjà dit moi le thème de sujets de
quoi tu veux débattre sais pas de quoi
je veux débat non je dis moi eh les mecs
c'est senna fera pas pousser non non et
non
c'est par une minute ou pas mais rien
n'est pas parce qu'on est à qui tu veux
parler
voilà pas ma mère je suis pas partir
voilà cela en 2001 non je l'aï mordu
l'oreille on a laissé parler sur l'a10
non mais de quoi tu as exactement de
quoi est paru ce qui s'est passé hier
soir est tu le sais très bien mais de
quoi que je teste ai dit quoi mes coudes
d'affronter arrête maintenant quoi mais
pourquoi tu me parles comme ça qu'est ce
qui te permet d'oser monter le ton de me
parler tu non mais je n'ai rien dit il
me dit non mais mais tout ça comment tu
peux t'exprimer
il attend quand c'est moi qui vais faire
de cette façon jamais des trente
secondes haletantes parle-moi gentiment
des maisonnettes aversion mon chéri
l'exigé pas fini gourdon s'est pressée
au parc monceau mon cher de l'élite
orange mais ouais mais je fais ça c'est
la faire quand même
moi j'estime bas appelle-t-on ya des
limites entre chroniqueurs et que la
moindre des choses c'est arrivé sur un
plateau de télévision avec la tête à
l'endroit
et ça ne gagnent nature et droite
d'arrivée surtout dans cette allée
serrer voulait
c'est vers 10hoo samedi soir
on attendait
quand tu compagne qu'il a été un petit
peu plus ici même si je peux comprendre
aux fusions mais les initiés par la
vidéo mon chéri tu te rends compte
il ya plein de gens venus dire pire j'ai
tout étonné pays des fous voilà allez on
aurait pu par mois avez vous déjà allé
fait c'est la version de zeus et
j'aurais pu le lire pierre moi je sais
que je regrette qu'on serre la main et
sexy oui c'est vrai ce que tu regrettes
les dogues c'est vrai que c'était dur
quand même ce que tu as fait d'après
cette vidéo mon chéri pour lui parce que
le postulat fait passer pour un mec qui
faisait des sketches raciste bah oui
c'est ça mon chinois
les jours une bonne ambiance entre nous
y voilà et faites vous un bisou
faussement c'est un peu que j'ai
mais hier ils vont bien dans ce qu'il
est dans son monde alors c'est vrai que
voilà moi j'ai axé mon pote depuis 15
ans et je laime comme ça et c'est un mec
un vrai gentil tout comme eric et
franchement il n'y a pas de polémique
là-dessus
voilà on rigolait dans cette émission on
est là pour rigoler mon chéri direct a
cru qu'il avait fait un sketch raciste
et je comprends maintenant je vais te
donner demandé juste un truc je suis
mieux les missions
voilà si tu subis dans l'émission